today we're reviewing not my job said
reddit I can't speak help me I really
excited for this this is recommended by
one of you guys based on the live
subreddit of people doing things very
poorly I don't know why this stuff
pissed me off so much so I expect to get
very angry install that soap dispenser
boss what I don't get it once that's
plugged in it's not gonna do anything
come on come on I want real I want
realness I want anger not laughter
someone just put down a fresh coat of
yellow paint on the subway platform edge
at 9:30 on a Wednesday morning this
platinum is going to be a mess of yellow
footprints by the end of the day what is
going on it's hard to think of a better
metaphor for how colossally mismanaged
the MTA and the New York City subway in
particular is update the result has been
expected yeah what the hell are you
thinking I need you to do this job okay
did it
you okay I hate that so much I did the
job I did what you asked another reason
I love Japan well it comes with pros and
cons but at least they take their job
seriously recently invited to speak at a
conference and was asked which of my two
affiliations I prefer to go on by name
tag probably university of central
lancashire I replied so that's what they
put probably University of probably
that's what you said how can you be so
dumb Jesus Christ stop being dumb stop
it
where's my Tambor oh I'm using his mouse
pad you win this round maybe he should
hire someone for that president
spokesman says he can't my job I can't
do that it ain't gonna happen man but
you are the the spoke man for the
spokeman
when the welshed flag is beyond your
artistic capabilities the drudes pub
Brighton Oh Brighton great all right
what do we got dried dragon it's a
dragon that's funny yeah I do this thing
where I laughed and then I say it's
funny afterwards I know I'm just quirky
like that everyone always the points
that I was so annoying so far I'm
waiting to get pissed off this is the
- funny I don't like it stop making
funny UPS men we are home please knock
loudly thanks thanks UPS man I did my
job yeah they love handing out those
things goddammit it muffin and job bank
and mouthful and job this is how Daris
is big delivered my Rs 600 carbon-fiber
violin bow to me broken in half to fit
their tiny plastic wrapping
pack that good luck girls or as the same
Japanese speaks I anticipate oh the
place to be not Sacramento Sacramento
Manette oh my colleague ordered some
balls online and this one came exactly
as you see it someone wrapped a broken
bowl without the parts that broke off
meaning
[Laughter]
that's a scummy that's not this is not
what I wanted goddamnit I want the anger
there it is now that's the soccer field
well done well done whoever did that you
did your job you did it and you did it
good hope you're proud are they drunk
when they did it dear customer your
Amazon account will be suspended to
avoid login reporting you two scammer
this is a group text scam seems like a
strange way to cut corners yes a group
text scan oh it's a group text just put
Monday that's before Monday the next
Monday obviously now that's a good job
that looks about right as if I did it I
would say Oh another one
Wow oh there's a corner here how do we
solve this that looks good that looks
nice I like that that'll be 30 grand
thank you very much what's the
difference between ultra boost three and
four hi I'm Daniel P I'll be assisting
you today what's up how may I help you
today I hate how they do that you have
to repeat what you only rewritten can't
they just get in three it's like they're
instructed to do this for man let it be
like hello hello sir my name is I'm
gonna ignore this message that you write
wrote out so you can write it out again
all right I wanted to know what the
difference between three and four is
please give me 2 to 2 minutes 2 to 2
minutes while I look into this alright
main the main difference is basically
that poor it's new wear yeah but what's
new at chat clothes because agent had
disconnected I rest my case
I've done my work here thank you very
much installing a door stopper all right
what do we got
are you installed it on the door oh wow
even better even better yeah we saw the
doors up around the doorway
everyone should I don't know what the
WTF she said here nice speaks Japanese
just whenever in doubt speaks Japanese
that's what the adidas one should have
said speaks Japanese no what a scumbag
be serious
well someone is fed up with not having a
mailbox Jesus okay so this person mode
their lawn and then the neighbors mond
it the day after but they didn't mom the
line hey my [ __ ] job hey my job and
out my job man I can't do that got your
new solar panel set up us that would be
30 grand thank you very much they run
under the shadows hey Jerry can you
dress that mannequin say no more of us I
got you fam done oh my god
I put the ended up bus I did it bus are
they old fast in the title that's funny
yeah it is ray the engraving boss didn't
I want any engraving just leave the
matter blank back like no a craving did
it boss
you did what you said boss you're
welcome boss finish installing the
sensors buzz no that's hilarious
besides our boss notice the pet is patio
patio cut patio a patio that's it it's
currently not opened because it is
closed Wow
Thank You patio Thank You patio so much
hey there goes here hater be like good
job good job guys legal stuff apply he's
all that legal stuff that applies right
here on all my videos as well all the
legal stuff applies all of them which
part
we are currently out of chocolate milk
gallons we are sorry we are so sorry for
the convenience ah jeez goddammit I
can't believe they're out fixed em
broken gosh pop rock bars I did it
probably the most accurate visual
representation of the United States
educational system right there boss I
did it boss I gotta go pee boss so ed
guy you finished a video boss I cut the
tomato boss the titles make it so much
funnier I put the lines buzz close
enough buzz I Drive my very best cone
cone hey Jerry can you put up a sign
that we got cones now I did it buzz this
cones now egg and cheese bagel coming
right up bus you would give adulation oh
my god
why is it so funny I did it but but the
later chapters done this item is reduced
due to misspelling of the word bird
thank you thank you thank you buy it
bread you want bread come on you want
bread bread mail the package buzz it's a
surprise party for my mother and we live
together so please can the Box not look
obvious delivery instructions nice
[Laughter]
the QR codes sort of gave up be the end
to you know it's a guy that's why I'm
saying it Oh God did the QR code boss
proofreading this book she couldn't have
been hot that hard
five five bananas boss I got your Bob's
no problem
Swedish not to the porn
what the hell Sweden uh you don't have
any dignity with your work
goddamn it's kind of funny though I'm
still the phone boss hastily a telephone
and balls a yute Oh God
my job is not to clean my job is to draw
lines you understand I did the work boss
come on come on Bosch pay me 30 grand
come on man another one another one just
take it down goddamn it how is this
possible that someone went through the
effort to install that and just be like
yeah okay this is the perfect example
because they know that they're doing it
wrong there's no way a human being can
go like oh yeah maybe this is this is it
yeah this is it
they just did it so they can say I did
it it's I hate that's so much I'm a
fanning stroller you see I'm not a
pillar remover you understand me but my
job is to deliver packages not read
signs bars I'm sorry I left them on the
hooks
[Laughter]
God you better not slack up on your job
don't do this don't be this guy I don't
understand even how that's possible
that can't be real it was a bit of hot
outside boss I'm sorry I named the
streets bus we got that Street this
street the other Street I can keep going
bye
no no install the who powers I just on
the hoop for the carbines no problem
okay I change the sign oh that's even
effort to do that why would my boss told
me to have a good day so I went home I
stole the rain the raid got a buzz
work down buzz need to pull fix say no
more buzz I know just the thing it's
like a major safety hazard right there
like no problem before Jerry Jeff for
two too many times
there's a sale Jeff got too many hams
ready that's my favorite kind of sale
god damn it Jeff it's always a jade
something I knew it I knew it
[Laughter]
everyone crashes into the other side
this is kind of subarray that just makes
you lose hope in humanity and we're like
the really this is the quality I washed
a sidewalk bus I sprayed a little bit
here and there but no problem yeah it's
time for my break boss 30 K bars I'm
Jeff good thing they're security bugs
don't worry I've put it up yeah lock
them in nice oh yeah it took me seven
tries but I got there boss no problem
departing I can't believe there's so
much ineptitude he blows oh god no
packaging dumb [ __ ] you never know what
you're gonna get with these subreddits
I'm trying to think if I ever done a bad
job I feel like I was instructed to do a
bad jobs and technically I was doing my
job but I was doing it badly so it was
now thanks for the instructions boss
couldn't have done it without a
Oh God great
what how is this not only did someone
build a frame through the ladder they
decided to shingle over it oh my god
unbelievable we install the handicapped
button bus
here you go handicaps your work we open
door for yah yah yah it is funny I say
it's funny after it's funny shut up oh
my god Jesus Christ stop it did it buy
stuff one but I managed to blow through
they they just put cement bags in the
pothole yeah I did what she writes I've
put the cement temper oh why why are you
like this all right I did it
I did the video boss hope you guys
enjoyed it it was a reddit video but
damn it
that was fun hopefully you guys enjoyed
if you did hit like make sure to become
a member get early access to epic live
streams epic avatars epic emojis and
just epicness in general thanks for
watching see you guys in two days or one
day one day see you guys in one hey it's
not my job to figure out all right sighs
you put something not my job oh you
think your floor gang will prove it sit
down and
download pixel ings right now the fourth
chapter is finally out or say you
haven't played it yet what's wrong with
you
sounds like someone is in the ceiling
hotdog download now
[Music]